The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Hi, my
name is Pramook Khungum.
I'm supposed to be one
of four, but it remains
that I am the only one now.
So my project was about
global illumination.
And it's about
rendering 3D scenes.
So first, let me tell you about
the direct illumination model.
This is something you can
achieve with ray tracing.
As you can see,
the image above is
rendered by shooting
a ray from your eyes,
and then taking
the local lighting
properties of the
materials, and then
see whether there's a light
coming to that point or not,
and then figure out the color.
So in this model, there's a lot
things unnatural about this.
Because as we can see, the
light is an area light,
but then the shadow
is very solid shadow
as if it's lit by a point
light or something like that.
And you can see that the
ceiling is not lit at all.
This means that this
model of lighting
doesn't take into
account the light that
bounces between the
walls and lighting
parts that should have been
lit in the real life scene,
as you can see.
So global illumination
basically tries to fix that.
And the effects you can achieve
with global illumination
algorithms are
basically soft shadows,
color bleeding-- you
can see that there's
a very pale shades
of blue here--
and caustics, which means
that light from here
goes through the glasses
and then focus on here.
So at first when I
started the project,
I wanted to globally illuminate
a very simple scene, which
is the Cornell Box.
So it's basically this box, and
you replace these two spheres
with two white boxes.
And then you can observe
color bleeding in something
like that.
And I wanted to do it in
real time with caustics.
However, the things I
accomplished are-- well,
I globally illuminated the
Cornell Box as I promised.
In real time--
no, it's too slow.
With caustic, didn't
implement photon mapping.
And sadly, there's still a
lot of room for optimization.
So kind of disappointed
myself a little bit, but yeah,
that's fine.
So the algorithm I used
for global illumination
is called Instant Radiosity.
It's by some German guy
called Alexander Keller.
It's good for scenes with
diffuse objects, which
means that scenes
that doesn't have
objects that reflect light or
lets light transmit through.
Diffuse objects can be just this
table and something like that.
Basically, it means that
when light strikes it,
it just bounces off randomly.
As such, it can't do
caustics, although it
is very simple to implement
once you have the core.
So let me describe
the algorithm.
You start with the
light source, and then
you emit artificial
light particles
and let them bounce
around the scene.
And then you will have
some more light source.
And then you ray trace
using those light sources
in the scene basically.
So this is the illustration
of the algorithm.
First, you have the
light, which goes off
from this square light.
And then you illuminate
the scene with it.
And then you bounce
some lights off,
and then illuminate the scene.
Then you combine the
results, basically.
So in my implementation,
at the beginning,
I have one SPU scatter
all the light particles.
The number of light particles
I scattered is about 128.
And as they bounce
around, it ends up
to be about 250 light
sources in total.
And then I rendered a scene
by splitting the scene
into horizontal slabs, and then
just give the slabs to each SPU
to render.
In this way, since the
scene is very small,
it can just preload
them to every SPU.
And they all can
work independently.
So there's minimal
communication going around.
And since I didn't implement
any other smart data structure
to take care of the
geometry, it just
used bruteforce ray tracing.
My scenes have only
eight objects anyway.
I wasn't maybe it
might be a good point
to see if there's
[? a question. ?]
AUDIENCE: So the SPUs are
doing rendering or ray tracing?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Ray
tracing, yes, basically.
AUDIENCE: But I mean, can a ray
move from one slab to another
depending on reflection
or something?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: No.
Basically, if you
trace the light there,
the SPU has all the
ascription of the scene,
so it can trace the ray
throughout the scene.
But it's responsible for
only the pixels in the slab.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: The
complexity is kind of bad
because the time is
you have your image
size, the number of pixels times
the number of light particles,
which is about 200.
And then since I used
bruteforce ray shooting,
you have to times by
the size of objects.
But at first, I thought
I have only eight objects
anyway so it's not going to
be a big performance rack.
But then I came
to the realization
that this algorithm
initially was conceived
for using with programmable
graphics hardware, which
can do really dumb tasks like
taking a point light source
and illuminating a scene
with shadows very fast.
So it turns out that this
algorithm is not really suited
for the [? Cell, ?] basically.
I wish I could have
done better on this.
This 512 times 512 scene
took 20 seconds to render
on the [? Cell. ?] But
the original paper, they
rendered something
a little bigger
than this in 24 seconds
with GPU basically,
so it's kind of disappointing.
PROFESSOR SAMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Hello?
PROFESSOR SAMAN: 24 seconds
on what type of a machine?
Can you hear me?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes,
but not very clearly.
AUDIENCE: 24 seconds on
what kind of a machine?
PROFESSOR SAMAN: The original
paper took 24 seconds?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: 24 seconds on
a 75 megahertz something machine
with a GPU.
PROFESSOR SAMAN: OK.
And did you try without using
any SPU, just using CPU?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Just using the
CPU and the GPU and that one.
PROFESSOR: His question
was, did you try using--
PROFESSOR SAMAN: If you just
use CPU without any parallelism,
how much time does it take?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM:
Oh, times that by 6.
However, the speedup is
proportional to the number
of processors you used.
I basically graphed the runtime
with the number of processors.
This is in [INAUDIBLE] scale.
So as you can see,
it-- so that's
the best you can do about
parallelism there, basically.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So runtime is
normalized to just the PPU?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Using the SPU.
AUDIENCE: So what are
the units for the y-axis?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: The y-axis
is runtime in seconds.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So 3.7 seconds, 3.6
seconds for one SPU?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes.
3.6 seconds per one SPU.
And as you increase,
the times go down.
You just divide that by that.
Is that clear?
AUDIENCE: And they're all
using the PPU as well?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: No, the
PPU doesn't do anything.
I just used--
AUDIENCE: Sorry, did you say 20
seconds on your previous slide?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: This is
different [? image ?] slides.
AUDIENCE: 128 by 128.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
OK, different--
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Sorry,
I didn't make that clear.
AUDIENCE: Sure, OK.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: This is 128.
So it's about 16 times faster.
I couldn't wait for llike--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yeah.
So here are some
images I rendered.
There are eight objects in here.
And it took like 20.5
seconds with six SPUs.
Another image that I rendered
is a miniature of a Cornell Box.
It took 20.2 seconds
and six SPUs.
AUDIENCE: Why is the
ceiling still so in black?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes, I
don't know that as well.
Maybe it's about
the distribution
of the particle light source.
Probably I think when it goes
to the wall or to the floor,
it gets severely attenuated
that it cannot really light
the ceiling basically.
So there's a comparison
between my rendering
and the real Cornell Box.
Basically, yes, there are still
a lot of [? boxes ?] around.
Basically, the
ceiling is not lit.
And it's kind of strange that
I see some gray tinges here
instead of green as in this one.
So probably, I have
to fix that as well.
But as you can see, we have
achieved soft shadows and then
some color bleeding.
AUDIENCE: How do you
determine the location
of the light sources?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: How
do I determine the--
AUDIENCE: Are you--
PROFESSOR: Are you
giving this input
to the algorithm, the
location of the light source?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes, basically.
AUDIENCE: And they
can be arbitrary
positions within the box or?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes, basically.
This one is just
a square object,
which is written in the
scene description file.
And I can locate them
wherever I want basically.
And the light particles
goes down from here.
So there are some things that
can be further optimized.
Basically, if I had decided
to use accelerated data
structure, the complexity of
that in that size times objects
times the number
of light sources,
this term will be
reduced to [? log. ?]
And probably, you
see about 3x speedup.
AUDIENCE: Can you give an
example of an accelerated
[? structure? ?]
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM:
Basically, the most popular
one is probably the--
what's it called?
For example,
[? the KD tree, ?] for example.
AUDIENCE: Oh, is it? [? OK. ?]
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: And
actually, I learned in class
that basically, you can
achieve about 2x or 3x speedup
by rearranging the data so that
you can trace four rays or 16
rays at a time instead of doing
one at a time in the approach
I'm taking.
And if you do that, it's faster.
In the program, I
have a lot of objects.
And each of them has a
transform associated to them
so that I can locate them
wherever I want and the object
can be anything.
But there's another
approach which
says I just take anything to
be a collection of triangles.
And if you have
triangles, the description
is just three points
in space and you
don't need transform to
do location or something
like that.
And basically, checking whether
a ray hits a triangle or not
will be faster.
So thank you very much.
PROFESSOR: A few more questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you
know that work that
was done here by Julie
Dorsey in illumination?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM:
I have [? not. ?]
AUDIENCE: She basically used
the trick of pre-computing,
doing the ray tracing for
some fixed number of source
locations and then just
rendering, in real time,
by taking a linear superposition
of these ray-traced images.
So long as you can
approximate your light source
by a linear combination
of some fixed repertoire
of light sources--
you didn't think
about taking that
shortcut presumably.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: I didn't think
about that shortcut basically.
I [INAUDIBLE] know
something like that's--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
few minutes left.
AUDIENCE: Good.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Let's see.
So [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So is it possible
to just connect it directly
to a Playstation 3?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: So
basically, there's
this output.gga, which I'm
going to remove because I'm
going to generate it.
The scene I'm going
to render is going
to be a Cornell Box with
a cube and a sphere in it.
AUDIENCE: Pramook?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes?
AUDIENCE: How easily could
you change the light sources?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: I can
just move the object
and the light source.
AUDIENCE: OK, can you
do that [INAUDIBLE]?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Sure.
Let's change it a point
light source then.
[INAUDIBLE] relax.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[? PROFESSOR: It just ?]
might be too slow.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: I see.
Here we go.
So right now, the current
light source is this square.
I'm going to comment it out and
change it to the point light
source here.
And then here we go.
That's too quick, but--
basically, there's
a point light source
located around here.
So the scene is lit
with one point light.
So as to expected,
the shadow is hard.
AUDIENCE: One more question.
PROFESSOR: One more question.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Just dividing
the scene equally
seems like it give
good load balancing.
If you had like roughly
equal complexity
across different
sections-- if you
have a really complex object
or if you have reflections that
go much deeper in
some places in others,
couldn't an equal division
lead to bad load balancing?
Did you think about
other divisions?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: I suppose.
But basically, other
approach that I think of,
which basically probably
you can divide the scene
in a really fine-grain manner.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you just do
like [? that striping. ?]
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
So is there a reason that
you chose [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR SAMAN:
The communication
how hard was it to get
this communication working?
So what [? you've ?]
communicated,
how often do you communicate?
PROFESSOR: Repeat the question.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM:
Professor Saman asked
how often does the SPU
communicate with one another,
and the PPU, and how
often do I do that?
PROFESSOR SAMAN: Yes.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM:
Basically, well,
before the SPU starts
running, the PPU
sends it the scene description.
And then it sends it
the task that says,
I want you to render
this pixel to this pixel.
And that's it.
And then the SPU just streams
the pixels to the main memory.
PROFESSOR SAMAN: OK, so
you do a static balance,
static distribution
of work [? around? ?]
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes.
PROFESSOR SAMAN: And
then when they're done,
everybody sends it back,
and then you synchronize?
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Yes.
PROFESSOR SAMAN: OK.
PRAMOOK KHUNGUM: Basically.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
thank the speaker.
[APPLAUSE]